Nightcap. Friday, April twenty-fourth, twenty twenty-six. Not what you need
to know — what changed, what landed, and one thing
worth sitting with. First up, the Scorecard. What moved since
this morning. Six markets on the board tonight. Anthropic greater-than
OpenAI twenty twenty-six: sixty percent this morning, fifty-eight point three
percent tonight. Down one point seven. Hormuz normal by April
thirtieth: eight percent this morning, eight point one percent tonight.
Flat. Iran retaliates by July first: sixty-eight percent this morning,
forty-one percent tonight. Down twenty-seven points — which is a
flag, not a read. Blockade forty-eight hours by July: eighty-six
point one percent, first evening pull, consistent with the week.
Brent crude above one hundred ten dollars by June thirtieth:
seventy-nine percent to seventy-seven point eight percent. Down one point
two. Apple foldable by twenty twenty-six: eighty-five percent, flat. One
line reading. The Iran-retaliates market swung almost thirty points toward
"won't" during a single trading day. That is not a
news-driven move — the shoot-and-kill order didn't get reversed, the
ships didn't come home, and no tanker transited Hormuz today.
That is a thin-liquidity market move. Total liquidity is only
one hundred mana; twenty-four hour volume was one hundred twenty-two.
A single conviction NO bet could have walked the line
twenty-seven points. File it as "market moved, world didn't" and
watch whether Monday's volume brings it back toward the news-supported
sixties. Anthropic kept its stubborn drift — down another one
point seven points to fifty-eight point three percent, continuing the
slide off the April twenty-second high of sixty-four percent. The
more interesting datum: the market hadn't yet priced in the
Google forty-billion-dollar story when I pulled it. Last bet on
that market was nine thirty-four P-M Central, right at pull
time. So tonight's fifty-eight point three percent is mostly a
Friday-afternoon-before-Bloomberg-broke number. Whether Monday morning opens above sixty percent or
not is the cleanest single read on how the market
values a forty-billion-dollar commitment from the company with the biggest
reason to want a stake. Hormuz markets are a rounding
error from this morning. The blockade-forty-eight-hour pull at eighty-six point
one percent is consistent with where it's been all week.
Markets continue to treat the blockade as structural and durable
regardless of the diplomatic noise. Next, The Plot Thickens. Google
is plowing up to forty billion dollars into Anthropic. This
is the story of the day, and it landed mid-afternoon
— not on the morning radar. Bloomberg broke it; Reuters
confirmed. Terms as reported: ten billion dollars in cash now
at a three-hundred-fifty-billion-dollar valuation, with another thirty billion potentially to
follow. Same valuation as February. Bloomberg's own gift link hit
the top of r slash ClaudeAI; the Reuters piece hit
number three on r slash technology with over a thousand
upvotes. The structural read. Anthropic's two biggest investors are now
Amazon and Google — at roughly thirty-three billion and up-to-forty
billion respectively. That is roughly seventy billion plus of committed
and potential investment from two companies that sell competing foundation
models. The arms-length story that used to describe these relationships
gets harder to tell. This is the fifth Anthropic capital
story in nine days. Monday: Amazon up-to-twenty-five billion plus one
hundred billion A-W-S commit plus five gigawatts of compute. Wednesday:
one trillion dollar secondary. Thursday: N-E-C partnership. Today: Google forty
billion. The pattern isn't "one big round" — it's continuous,
layered, from multiple counterparties. The three-hundred-fifty-billion-dollar valuation is the same
as February. This is not a markup round. Google paid
the February price to keep its seat at the table
while Amazon was buying more. The message is access, not
markup. The disconnect worth flagging: none of this has shown
up in the prediction market yet. Anthropic-greater-than-OpenAI twenty twenty-six is
down on the day, not up. Either the market is
slow and Monday corrects, or there's something about the "Anthropic
competes with its own investors" arrangement that traders are reading
as a ceiling rather than a floor. Worth naming, not
worth concluding yet. The Iran ships. No material change from
morning. Epaminondas still showing moved-north into Iranian territorial waters. Francesca
still dark. No new seizures, no combat, no transits. Iran
is consolidating the hostages, not returning them. Same as morning.
r slash ClaudeAI warmer but weirder. The limit-reset absorbed the
anger, as predicted. The new story is cost. Top post
of the day is a meme — "I'm somewhat of
a coder myself" at three thousand six hundred upvotes —
but the most representative thread is "Claude is extremely expensive
but works like Magic" at seventy-one upvotes, eighty-three percent upvote
ratio. Non-coders reporting that Claude is both the only thing
that works for their use case and financially painful. The
"A-I free ride is over" meta-story from the Verge this
morning is playing out in exactly the subreddit Anthropic reads
most closely. Pricing is the new temperature. Fresh Intel. Stories
not on this morning's radar. Twenty thousand layoffs at Meta
and Microsoft this week, now being explicitly framed as the
start of the A-I labor crisis. C-N-B-C ran the headline:
"Twenty K job cuts at Meta, Microsoft raise concern that
A-I-driven labor crisis is here." r slash technology is pushing
the story — fourteen hundred upvotes. This is the demand-side
companion to the Apprenticeship Crisis concept note built yesterday: if
the first-order effect of A-I is entry-level jobs disappearing, the
second-order effect showing up now is mid-career displacement at the
largest employers. The Wired Palantir piece — "Palantir Employees Are
Starting to Wonder if They're the Bad Guys" — hit
seven thousand seven hundred upvotes and is the culture-side story
of the same week. A-I is compressing white-collar work, and
the most A-I-forward companies are the ones where employees are
starting to ask harder questions out loud. Maine vetoed a
data center ban. Governor Janet Mills vetoed the Maine data
center moratorium bill today. Bangor Daily News has it. Mother
Jones has the companion piece framing Maine as the front
of a broader state-level pushback even though the ban itself
was blocked. For the Anthropic-Missouri-data-center-siting thread you've been tracking: the
policy window on data center moratoriums is opening state by
state, and the governor veto is now the move the
industry has to count on. Watch whether Missouri's legislature files
anything similar next session. Utah medical board called for an
immediate suspension of the state's A-I doctor experiment. S-T-A-T reported
it. This is the first state-level regulatory pushback on A-I-as-clinician
that's actually gotten a medical board behind it. It's small
today; it's a precedent tomorrow. Connects to why Anthropic's "enterprise-first
plus safety-first" differentiation keeps mattering — when the regulatory pushback
arrives, the labs that shipped with careful framing are the
ones still in the room. G-P-T five-point-five SimpleBench scores dropped.
r slash singularity posted the chart today. The published numbers
are a real step-up over G-P-T five-point-four but narrower margins
than OpenAI's own comparison suggested. SimpleBench is one of the
benchmarks designed to catch pattern-matching dressed up as reasoning —
so how G-P-T five-point-five scores there is one of the
cleaner tells. The model is strong but not the step-change
the launch rhetoric implied. Combined with the A-P-I gap, still
not available for third-party verification, this reinforces the morning's read:
G-P-T five-point-five is a capable new frontier model, not a
category reset. That matters for the val market drift —
the "OpenAI leapfrogged" thesis is narrower than it looked Thursday.
Messages tonight. Quiet. No new iMessages since morning. Katelyn hasn't
sent anything after last night's rabbit-hole texts; the Merlin photos
and movie notes are still the last word on that
thread. Today's ask — put a date on "later" —
carries to tomorrow. Dustin, Alex Kelley, and the weekend-plans thread
all sit where they were this morning. One quiet day
of message traffic on a day that was otherwise loud
with news. Interesting by its contrast. Vault delta. Today was
the most structurally productive vault day in months. Git got
unblocked. The vault had been stuck on a branch for
over a month with three stale lock files. Cleared, merged,
pushed. Remote now synced. The .claude memory is now tracked
in git. It had been entirely gitignored, meaning current-context, decisions,
and every skill file was one disk failure away from
disappearing. Fixed. The Apprenticeship Crisis concept note got built. Candidate
had been sitting for a week with no verdict. Now
lives at The-Apprenticeship-Crisis. This is the note that gets refreshed
by tonight's Meta, Microsoft, and Palantir stories. The career folder
got triaged. Sixty-five pre-twenty twenty-five files archived, seven Anthropic posting
snapshots consolidated. The Daily Briefings folder got sub-organized. A hundred
fifty flat files sorted into artwork, transcripts, scripts, charts, and
audio. And the nightcap scheduled task itself got created today.
Tonight is the first real run. Tomorrow setup. Weather. Jefferson
City: sunny, high seventy-eight, zero percent precipitation, light northeast wind.
Clean morning-run day — best weather window for a long
run all weekend, because Sunday night and Monday are picking
up storms. The big one: W-A flights. Target was Sunday
April twenty-sixth for the July twenty-third to July thirtieth window,
ninety-one days out. That target is one day away. Booking
tomorrow over Saturday coffee is cleaner than booking Sunday on
deadline. It also gives you a concrete answer to put
into the conversation with Katelyn when "later" comes up: "I
booked the July flights, when do you want to talk
about August." Specific beats aspirational. Calendar. Empty tomorrow. No events
to prepare for. Saturday is yours — for flights, a
long run, and the Katelyn conversation when she's up. Watch
overnight and Monday: whether the Anthropic val market rerates up
on the Google forty-billion news, and whether the Iran-retaliates market
snaps back toward the sixties on Monday volume. One Thing
to Sit With. The Nightcap is running for the first
time tonight. It was a file sitting in the folder
since April sixteenth titled SETUP-NEW-TASKS dot md — a to-do
that said, roughly, build the evening briefing. It sat there
for eight days. It got built today, inside the larger
vault cleanup session, and queued up for its first real
run at nine-oh-nine P-M Central. Today was also the day:
Google committed up to forty billion dollars to Anthropic. Meta
and Microsoft laid off twenty thousand people combined, and the
framing crossed the threshold from restructuring to A-I-driven labor crisis.
Maine's governor vetoed a data center ban. Utah's medical board
called for suspending its state A-I-doctor experiment. A Wired piece
asked whether Palantir employees are the bad guys and it
hit the top of tech news. And a prediction market
moved twenty-seven points on one hundred twenty-two mana of volume.
The week had G-P-T five-point-five, DeepSeek V-four, Anthropic's Mozilla-Mythos post,
a Claude Code post-mortem, two anchor partnerships, an N-E-C announcement,
a shoot-and-kill order, ship consolidations, a memory correction on a
conversation with someone you love, and — quietly, in the
corner of a vault-cleanup session — the construction of the
small piece of infrastructure that made this summary possible. The
question worth sitting with: most of the things that actually
matter this year are not news events — they are
pieces of infrastructure someone built quietly on a Friday and
then never mentioned again. Which of the unbuilt files sitting
in your folders right now is the one? Good night.